hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video seht wahrscheinlich schon und
hitler eingeblendet und zwar etwas mit
killer clowns das ist ja derzeit
wirklich in den medien eigentlich
überall vertreten und ich werde morgen
wahrscheinlich auch noch mal ein video
dazu machen wie ich allgemein dazu stehe
weil das irgendwie alles ein bisschen
bescheuert und überhaupt ist aber dass
kommen morgen das wird dann aus einem
live-video wo ich mich wieder auf mein
bett nach vorne setzte heute habe ich
mir einfach mal gedacht das ist jetzt
schon dunkel draußen ich komm war das
hockeyspielen doch einfach mal ein
killer clown spiel und zwar clown killer
zwei bestes spiel des jahres ich hab den
sound übrigen schon ausgemacht weil
schaut man menschen von an hätte
das ist nur noch einen absacker deswegen
passt einfach meine eigene musik hinter
die grafik packe ich mal kurz auf high
und dann würde ich sagen spielen wir
einfach mal den story lotis bitte hier
sind die clowns went on killings pebble
beach ist dort in bronze des trails of
the japanese majesty discovery memmingen
autos lag das kino hin
das heißt viel glück mit via sd laufen
wir und mit jkl schouten wir
beziehungsweise daten in verschiedene
richtungen übrigens versteht es nicht
falsch ich bin hier kein killer klauen
sondern ich töte kurz man mit diesem
komischen spaziert auf den straßen
eigentlich auch machen
wie gesagt so ein richtiges real-tor
video zu dieser ganzen scheiße mit den
killer clowns kommt morgen auf einem
kanal und da werd ich echt so ein paar
leute hochnehmen streicht euch den
kalender das video kommt von mir klicken
jetzt einfach mal auf start und zwar
müssen wir hier einfach verschiedene
zombie wellen so ein bisschen über
lehrer bei euch kann ja direkt daneben
80 muss hier alter schwede ich bin auf
jeden fall dieser typ hier und das ist
ein gesundheitskosten und wir müssen
hier die leute töten und ihr seht schon
freunde bestes spiel des jahres ich weiß
gar nicht ob ich jetzt nach rechts
laufen muss oder ob ich einfach alle
töten muss oder wie das jetzt hier genau
abläuft fällt irgendwie gewinne ich ja
gerade oder also hier kommt der
zumindest keiner jetzt bin ich gerade
hier konnte ich ein bisschen weiter
durchlaufen habe jetzt sogar hier vorne
ein
gerät das mit +25 gibt ich weiß nicht
genau was das heißt haben eine zeit aber
ich glaube die verlängert sich die ganze
wenn ich neue leute ab kellerabteile
luca wieder mit seinen wort
neuschöpfungen hier doch das heißt
neologismus wenn man sich neue wörter
überlegten wir sind neue wörter
irgendwie gründet und ich mach das
tatsächlich sehr häufig ich finds auch
einfach krass wie diese grafik hier
abgeht also ich meinen kopf durch den
hintergrund an
ist das nicht hammer ich zeige euch hier
mal wie das neue battlefield aussieht
und jetzt vergleich das mal mit diesem
clown killerspiel
ich glaube wir sind uns alle einig dass
kleinkinder auf jeden fall gewonnen hat
wenn ihr wieder an der wand angekommen
jetzt kommen wir von dieser seite wieder
leute elf leute ich könnte heulen etwas
was wollen die denn alle habe ich auch
irgendwann mal keine munition mehr weil
ich könnte er theoretisch die ganze zeit
schießen unter diesem spiel war
irgendwie angegeben dass es auch so
walkthrough dazu gibt aber wofür will
man ihn aber ich bin da wird zwar
wahrscheinlich gibt es jetzt auch noch
flammen oder da kommen flammen flammen
ich komm hier nicht weg ich glaube die
falschen leute die flammen waren rechts
an der wand und ich war auch rechts an
der wand und man kann nicht über die
flamme drüber sondern muss in die andere
richtung reifenentwickler denkt man nach
trotzdem besser als battlefield
definitiv schreibt mal alle killer clown
in die kommentare wenn ihr denkt dass
dieses spiel besser ist als battlefield
ich will 40.000 kommentare sehen leute
also mein score gerade war 7930 und ich
versuche den jetzt mal zu knacken das
ganze hat gerade angefangen und hier
kommen jetzt wieder die ganzen typischen
komischen leute den film ich dann die
töten was sind das für menschen nach ja
oder sind die clowns und ich musste
jetzt die clowns trifft das gegenteil
ist eigentlich gerade der fall in den
nachrichten beziehungsweise im
weltgeschehen das halt diese ganzen
killer clowns dann nachdem sie ich
glaube durch pearc durch den film serge
säuberung ist das ganze entstanden dass
die leute sich halt als clowns
verkleiden und leute erschrecken und das
irgendwie affig aber wie gesagt halt
morgen video zu luca geht hier seinen
weg schießt die ganzen leute erwartet es
neue kaum schießt ihn wartet bis sie
kommen schießt die absicht hier die
leute ab ist hemberger die tiere die
leute china dort mein score war
irgendwas zwischen 7000 und 8000 sagen
einfach mal 8000 war mein score das
203.000 punkte dann habe ich ihn aber
gleich komme ich auf jeden fall erstmal
wieder in das neue level und dann wird
krass weil da das feuer kommt also
vorher bis wirklich die ganze zeit
geschafft aber bis sie sind als dieses
feuer da kamen mir nicht so nicht so
bock was sind da schon wieder nur wenige
minuten später ich bin im zweiten level
angekommen ich hab so ein bisschen angst
vor diesem scheiß clowns alter das ist
das fakt nicht so ein bisschen ab weil
die händler die ganze zeit
voraussichtlich schon wieder dem feuer
alter was euch denn hier machen deutlich
hatten score von 8100 8200 und habe
damit quasi jetzt mein score geschafft
hey ich versuche jetzt einfach noch
irgendwie höher zu kommen
ihr müsst einfach mal googlen killer
clown killer 2 dann könnte das spiel
auch spielen also vielleicht seid ja
sogar besser als ich ich bin schon bei
dem score von 10.200 angekommen alter
mir kann eh keiner irgendwas machen
damit ich ihnen und das health package
ein loft bin tot
das was ihr vom video meine damen und
herren ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wenn es das getan hat las auf jeden fall
mehr aufgeht verfechterin dieses kissen
dass sie eingeblendet bekommt ihr im
video stoffe.de und außerdem wird es im
lukas shop auch am ersten 12 tim ca 5
neue produkte geben neues design neue
fotos neue aktionen alles wird anders
geschnitten sein antrag durch den ersten
zwölf in den kalender ein da oben findet
ihren smiley eingeblendet wenn er da
dort könnt ihr einen kanal abonnieren
und hier findet ihr ein anderes video
eingeblendet was ich euch da verlegt
weiß ich nicht ich glaube einfach den
block aus amsterdam den ich gestern
hochgeladen habe schreibt mal killer
clownin kommentare wenn ihr findet dass
das spiel was heutige später besser war
als battlefield 97 sonders wieder